POLITICAL COUP AGAINST THE
ANTIESTABLISHMENT FIGURE,
DONALD TRUMP.
AND THAT'S THE "ANGLE."
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION IS
THE AFTER MENTIONED CARTER PAGE,
A FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISOR
WHOM THE FBI SURVEILLED.
AS WELL AS MICHAEL CAVUTO, A
FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN AIDE WHO
HAS BEEN INTERVIEWED BY SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER STEAM.
GENTLEMEN, IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
YOU BOTH ON TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
CARTER, LET'S START WITH YOU.
YOU HAD A LOT OF CONTACT WITH
THIS INFORMANT, WHATEVER WE WANT
TO CALL THEM, INFORMANT, SPY,
MOLE.
AND I WANT TO READ ONE OF THE
EMAILS THAT HE SENT TO YOU THAT
WAS RELEASED BY I THINK IT WAS
DAILY CALLER GOT THIS INITIALLY.
DEAR CARTER, I THOUGHT IT RIGHT
AS THE SUMMER WEARS ON TO ASK
HOW YOU ARE AND WHAT YOUR PLANS
ARE AT THIS POINT.
IT SEEMS ATTENTION HAS SHIFTED A
BIT FROM THE COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION TO THE CONTEMPT
WITHIN THE WHITE HOUSE AND HOW
OR IF ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI WILL BE
ACCOMMODATED THERE.
I MUST ASSUME THIS GIVES YOU
SOME RELIEF.
WE ARE HERE IN VIRGINIA.
BE IN TOUCH IF YOU HAVE THE
TIME.
WOULD BE GREAT TO CATCH UP.
WE ARE NOT MENTIONING THE
INFORMANT'S NAME, BUT WHEN DID
YOU FIRST MEET THIS INFORMANT
THAT WE NOW KNOW IS AN INFORMANT
AND JUST BRIEFLY TELL US ABOUT
THAT EXCHANGE.
>> AGAIN, SIMILAR TO VIEW IN
TERMS OF BEING CAUTIOUS ABOUT
IDENTITY, I HAVE ALSO -- I NEVER
KNEW ANYTHING ABOUT THE PERSON I
WAS SPEAKING WITH WHO IS A
UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR AT
CAMBRIDGE IN THE U.K. AT THE
TIME.
I WAS INVITED TO PARTICIPATE IN
A CONFERENCE IN JULY OF 2016 AND
EVERYTHING SEEMED TOTALLY
NORMAL.
AND FRANKLY, I HAVE BEEN FALSELY
ACCUSED MYSELF AND WE WILL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IN TERMS OF AS
FURTHER DETAILS COME OUT.
BUT BASED ON EVERYTHING I'VE
SEEN THUS FAR, WE STILL DON'T
HAVE ANY INFORMATION.
>> Laura: WE KNOW HE WAS PAID
A MILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS.
PRETTY GOOD MONEY AS A
CONSULTANT, OR RESEARCHER.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT.
WE SHALL SEE.
BUT QUESTION, BEFORE WE GO ON TO
MICHAEL.
WHO STARTED THE CONVERSATION?
HOW DID THE DATE BEGIN?
SORRY, DID HE APPROACH YOU, DID
HE MENTION RUSSIA COLLUSION
FIRST?
HOW DID IT GO DOWN?
>> IT WAS A MULTI-DAY CONFERENCE
AND THERE WERE SCHOLARS AND
PEOPLE FROM GOVERNMENT BOTH FROM
THE UNITED KINGDOM -- JUST
>> Laura: STAY FOCUSED WITH
ME.
DID HE APPROACH YOU FIRST?
DID YOU APPROACH AND?
HOW DID YOU FIRST START
SPEAKING?
>> I DON'T EVEN RECALL.
WE SPENT A COUPLE DAYS TOGETHER.
>> Laura: A COUPLE DAYS
TOGETHER?
>> IT WAS A LONG EVENT OVER
SEVERAL DAYS.
>> Laura: WHAT I'M SAYING IS
THERE WERE A LOT OF SCHOLARS
THERE AND YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE
PROCESS OF GROOMING SOMEONE.
WHEN SOMEONE IS AN INFORMANT
THEY DON'T JUST GO UP TO SOMEONE
AND SAY HEY, I WANT TO PLANT
INFORMATION ON YOU OR FIND OUT
WHAT YOU HAVE.
YOU TRY TO WIN SOMEONE'S TRUST
OVER.
THAT'S HOW IT GOES.
>> I NEVER FELT GROOMED.
IF HE'S GOOD AT DOING THAT THEN
PERHAPS THAT'S PART OF THE GAME.
>> Laura: YOU DON'T KNOW WHO
MENTIONED THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
ISSUE FIRST?
>> I CAN'T EVEN REMEMBER.
I THINK RUSSIA WAS IN THE NEWS
AND I THINK A LOT OF POLITICS
SORT OF REVOLVED AROUND VARIOUS
NEWS EVENTS AND SOLD THESE
VARIOUS STORIES CAME UP.
AGAIN, WE STAYED IN TOUCH FOR
OVER A YEAR.
>> Laura: LOOKING BACK, I'M
SORRY TO INTERRUPT.
LIMITED TIME.
I'M LOOKING BACK ON IT, DOES
ANYTHING SEEM ODD OR -- YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THEN, MAYBE
THAT WAS A LITTLE ODD, OR ANY
OTHER CONTACTS HAD WITH ANY
OTHER PEOPLE THAT SEEM NOW IN
RETROSPECT GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW
NOW ODD, OUT OF THE ORDINARY OR
MAYBE IN SOME WAY IMPROPER?
>> I TEND TO GIVE PEOPLE THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
WE WILL SEE.
MAYBE THIS INDIVIDUAL WHO WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE BIT NICER THAN I MIGHT
OTHERWISE HAVE EXPECTED.
ALTHOUGH, WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
ALL OF THE ABUSES THAT WERE
HAPPENING WITH THIS DODGY
DOSSIER WHICH WAS FIRST DEBUTED
IN SEPTEMBER 2016 AS A WAY OF
DAMAGING THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
BASICALLY DESTROYING MYSELF, AND
SO HE ALWAYS SEEMED VERY
SYMPATHETIC ABOUT THAT.
AGAIN, WE'LL SEE.
I LIKE TO GIVE PEOPLE THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
PEOPLE THAT KNOW HIM IN
WASHINGTON AND SENIOR CIRCLES
THAT I HAVE SPOKEN WITH
AFTERWARDS SAY HE SEEMED LIKE A
PRETTY DECENT GUY.
>> Laura: THAT WOULD BE THE
PERFECT PERSON TO USE.
MAYBE I'M JUST CYNICAL, BEEN
AROUND WASHINGTON TOO LONG.
IF ONLY THEY GAVE YOU THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT LIKE YOU
ARE GIVING OTHER PEOPLE THE
BENEFIT OF THAT OUT.
MICHAEL, LET'S GO TO YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH THE
MEAT GRINDER AT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
HE HAS ALL THESE REALLY HIGHLY
SKILLED INTERVIEWERS,
PROSECUTORS ON HIS SIDE.
MANY OF THEM, NOT ALL OF THEM I
BELIEVE HAVE A BUILT-IN ANIMUS
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
YOU ARE VERY ANGRY THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN DRAGGED INTO THIS AS A
FORMER ASSOCIATE OF ROGER STONE.
YOU ALSO DID SOME WORK FOR THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
TELL US WHAT YOU THINK.
YOU JUST HEARD WHAT CARTER SAID
ABOUT THIS REPORTED INFORMANT
FOR THE FBI.
>> I THINK CARTER HAS BEEN
THROUGH MORE OF A MEAT GRINDER
THAT I HAVE IT HE HAS HANDLED IT
AS A GENTLEMAN.
IN FACT, WHEN I FIRST HEARD
ABOUT THE STUFF I THINK IN 2016
ABOUT CARTER I WASN'T VERY KIND
IN MY CRITICISM AND IT LOOKS
LIKE THEY WERE REALLY ABUSING
CARTER.
I THINK THEY WERE REALLY
TREATING HIM POORLY AND I THINK
A LOT OF US OWE CARTER AN
APOLOGY BECAUSE WE DIDN'T WAIT
TO HEAR THE TRUTH AT THE END AND
NOW WE ARE FINDING OUT THAT HIS
COUNTRY WAS REALLY FAILING HIM
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS AND EVEN
YEARS.
I'M ANGRY, I'M SURPRISED THAT
CARTER IS NOT.
HE'S A GREATER MAN THAN I.
THIS IS REALLY SICK AND TWISTED
STUFF.
AND LIKE CARTER SAID, THIS
GENTLEMAN WHO SHALL NOT BE NAMED
HAS A REPUTATION OF BEING VERY
PRO-AMERICAN, VERY PATRIOTIC AND
IF, IN FACT, HE WAS BROUGHT INTO
THIS UNDER FALSE CIRCUMSTANCES
OR FALSE PRETENSES AS WELL IS
THE KIND OF GUY THAT A DEEP
STATE WOULD TARGET.
>> Laura: THE DOSSIER WAS THE
BASIS FOR GETTING THIS FISA WAR.
I DON'T CARE WHAT THESE PEOPLE
SAY.
IT WAS ALL A BIG LIE.
WITHOUT THIS DOSSIER CARTER PAGE
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN SURVEILLED
IN THE FALL OF 2016.
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED.
THAT'S WHEN THEY WERE RUNNING TO
THAT RUSSIAN OLIGARCH TO TRY TO
GET HIM INVOLVED.
HE IS LIKE I DON'T EVEN LIKE
PAUL MANAFORT, THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
THEY WERE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
COULD.
THEY WERE WORKING THE PAGE
ANGLE.
THEY PROBABLY WERE WORKING THIS
INFORMANT ANGLE AND THEY BROUGHT
YOU IN, MICHAEL, WHICH WE WILL
GET YOU IN A MOMENT.
BUT I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU WHAT
SALLY ASKED, ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, SHE'S THE ONE
WHO WAS PARTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
INTERVIEWING MICHAEL FLYNN AT
THE BEGINNING, WHAT SHE SAID
TODAY ON MORNING JOE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I THINK WHAT WE ARE SEEING
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT HAS JUST
TAKEN HIS OUT OF SALT      ALL-O
TAKEN HIS OUT OF SALT      ALL-T
TAKEN HIS OUT OF SALT      ALL-A
TAKEN HIS OUT OF SALT      ALL-S
TAKEN HIS OUT OF SALT      ALL-U
TAKEN HIS OUT OF SALT      ALL-T
ON THE NEW LAW TO A NEW LEVEL IN
THIS TIME RESULT ORDERING AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATORS WHO ARE EXAMINING
HIS OWN CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S REALLY SHOCKING.
ROD ROSENSTEIN IS TRYING TO
STRIKE A BALANCE HERE BETWEEN
DIFFUSING THE SITUATION, BUT
ALSO PROTECTING THE RULE OF LAW
AND THE INSTITUTIONAL INTEGRITY
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
>> Laura: CARTER PAGE, AS I
POINTED OUT IN THE OPENING
"ANGLE," THE GOVERNMENT UNDER
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HAS
SURVEILLED PEOPLE AND LIED ABOUT
IT.
AND WHETHER IT WAS CLAPPER,
WHETHER IT WAS THE FBI UNDER
HOLDER SURVEILLING JOURNALISTS,
THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF HAVING A
PROBLEM TELLING THE TRUTH ON
SURVEILLING.
SO FOR SALLY ASKED TO RUN OUT
THERE AND SAY DONALD TRUMP IS
ATTACKING THE RULE OF LAW, COME
ON.
YOUR REACTION?
>> JUST GOING TO MICHAEL'S POINT
ABOUT THINGS THEY DID TO ME,
PRESIDENT TRUMP DURING THE
CAMPAIGN WOULD OFTEN SAY THIS IS
NOT ABOUT ME, THIS IS ABOUT US
AND I THINK OF ALL OF OF THE
TERRIBLE THINGS THAT HAPPEN TO
SO MANY PEOPLE LIKE MICHAEL,
SOME OF THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO
WERE INVOLVED ALLEGEDLY WITH
THIS INFORMANT, I ACTUALLY SPOKE
VERY POSITIVELY.
I GOT A POSITIVE IMPRESSION
ABOUT THIS INFORMANT.
A COUPLE OF PEOPLE I MENTIONED
HIM TO IN THE CAMPAIGN, I WAS
PRETTY POSITIVE ENDORSEMENT.
I HOPE AND PRAY THAT ALL THESE
ALLEGATIONS TURN OUT TO BE FALSE
AND PART OF WHY I'M SOMEWHAT
OPEN ABOUT MY COMMUNICATIONS
WITH HIM IS THAT IT WILL LEAD TO
SOME TRUTH FINALLY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I'VE BEEN ASKING FOR DOJ TO OWN
UP TO THESE THINGS AND IT'S
FUNNY, THE DEFAMATION SUIT I
HAVE AGAINST A TOP MEDIA
ORGANIZATION AND DOJ, THE MEDIA
ORGANIZATION IS ACTUALLY MUCH
MORE HONEST THAN THE FALSE
PLEADINGS BY THE DOJ SO FAR.
>> Laura: WE GOT TO PLAY THIS
JAMES CLAPPER FOR MICHAEL.
HE'S BASICALLY JUST JUSTIFYING
THE USE OF ANY TYPE OF INFORMANT
HERE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THE FOCUS HERE, AS IT WAS
WITH THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
IS NOT ON THE CAMPAIGN PER SE,
BUT WHAT THE RUSSIANS WERE DOING
TO TRY TO INSTANTIATE THEMSELVES
IN THE CAMPAIGN OR TO INFLUENCE
OR LEVERAGE IT.
SO IF THERE WAS SOMEONE THAT WAS
OBSERVING THAT SORT OF THING,
THAT'S A GOOD THING, BECAUSE THE
RUSSIANS POSE A THREAT TO THE
VERY BASIS OF OUR POLITICAL
SYSTEM.
>> Laura: MICHAEL.
DO YOU SEE A PATTERN HERE?
FORMER OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIAL JUSTIFYING SPYING ON,
SURVEILLING, WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO CALL IT, PUTTING THEM ALL IN
ON AN OPPOSING CAMPAIGN IN A
HOTLY CONTESTED ELECTION, FINAL
THOUGHT.
>> YOU HAVE SPENT TIME IN
RUSSIA, CARTER AND I BOTH HAVE.
IN RUSSIA THEY CALL THIS THE
NATIONAL SECURITY LEADERSHIP
THAT SECRETLY SPIES ON THE
CITIZENRY OF RUSSIA AND HERE WE
ARE IN THE UNITED STATES WITH
OUR OWN UNDERNEATH
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING THAT I
KNOW FOR A FACT.
THIS INFORMANT, THIS PERSON THAT
THEY PLANTED, TRY TO PLANT INTO
THE CAMPAIGN AND EVEN INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION IF YOU BELIEVE
AXIOS, HE'S NOT THE ONLY PERSON
THAT CAME AT THE CAMPAIGN AND
THE FBI IS NOT THE ONLY OBAMA
AGENCY THAT CAME AT THE
CAMPAIGN.
I KNOW BECAUSE THEY CAME AT ME
AND I'M LOOKING FOR CLEARANCE
FROM MY ATTORNEY TO REVEAL THIS
TO THE PUBLIC.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
AND I WILL TELL YOU, WHEN WE
FINALLY FIND OUT THE TRUTH ABOUT
THIS DIRECTOR KLAPPER AND THE
REST OF THEM ARE GOING TO BE
WEARING SOME ORANGE SUITS.
>> Laura: MICHAEL CAVUTO AND
CARTER PAGE, I HOPE WE GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS A LOT SOONER
THAN A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
PREDICTING BECAUSE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DESERVE TO KNOW WHO IS
BEHIND THIS, WHO AUTHORIZED IT